"The Walking Dead — Daryl Dixon" throws
a fan-favorite character across an ocean,
introduces a new dynamic, and leaves our hero
between a metaphorical rock and a hard place.
Here's what the ending of season one means.
Early on in "The Walking Dead: Daryl Dixon,"
Daryl manages to break free from his captors
and starts wandering France — searching
for a way home, running into some new walker
variants, and meeting plenty of new characters
along the way.
Where the original series focused on Daryl's
transformation from a "lone wolf" survivalist
to a beloved leader and a surrogate father
figure to R.J. and Judith Grimes, "Daryl Dixon"
explores this newfound empathy as Daryl becomes
the protector of a young boy named Laurent.
Laurent is a young boy who was born via C-section
after his mother had already turned into a
zombie, and who is now revered as the Messiah
by a religious network called the "Union of Hope."
Members of the Union believe Laurent is destined
to end the apocalypse and restore humanity
to its former glory.
"If we're wrong at least you will have helped
a boy get to a better place.
But if we're right…
Why not bet on hope?"
In a storyline that draws some parallels to
that of "The Last of Us," Daryl agrees to
transport this young savior across France
to the Union's base, though in Episode 5,
Daryl, Laurent, Laurent's father Quinn, and
the nun Isabelle are captured by agents of
the Pouvoir.
The episode ends on a cliffhanger, in which
Daryl is forced into a gladiator fight against
the enhanced walkers created by the Pouvoir,
while some members of the Union sneak into
the Pouvoir's arena to stage a desperate rescue
attempt.
The finale of "The Walking Dead: Daryl Dixon
” begins inside the gladiator pit, where
Daryl quickly defeats a few of the Pouvoir's
genetically enhanced walkers.
Quinn is sent in and chained to Daryl to provide
more of a challenge, though the pair still
manage to defeat wave after wave of these
new and improved zombies.
Their success draws a surprising amount of
support from the crowd, who start cheering
"Dixon" as Daryl and Quinn fight.
The enraged Pouvoir leader Genet decides to
execute Daryl and Quinn before things get
out of hand, but they're saved by a well-timed
bullet which kicks off a full-blown uproar
inside the arena.
In the ensuing chaos, Daryl and Quinn escape
their chains and Quinn reveals that he was
infected during their battle.
Quinn sacrifices himself to make way for Daryl
and Laurent's escape, declaring his love for
Isabelle — his former lover and Laurent's
biological aunt, who raised Laurent in Quinn's absence.
Daryl and his Union allies rush to free Isabelle
and Laurent from Pouvoir custody, though during
the final stage of their escape, they come
face-to-face with the reanimated corpse of Quinn.
In a heartbreaking turn of events, Laurent
is forced to kill the walker who was once
his father, saving Isabelle and later declaring:
"It wasn't him anymore.
That man was never my father."
With Quinn put down for good, the group completes
their escape from the arena and splits up
on the road.
Fallou and Emile depart into the woods while
the rest flee towards Mont Saint-Michel.
Along the way, Isabelle confesses to Daryl
that she invented a good deal of Laurent's
"Messianic" powers, hoping to impress Daryl
and draw support for the Union.
Oddly, this brief confession is juxtaposed
with a roadside ambush from Pouvoir agents
led by Stéphane Codron, where Laurent displays
an eerie level of persuasion that borders
on the supernatural.
Laurent imparts a "message from God" and somehow
convinces Codron to gun down his fellow agent,
allowing Isabelle, Daryl, and Laurent to continue
on their way.
Finally, the trio arrives in the fortified
city of Mont Saint-Michel, where the religious
haven known as "The Nest" resides.
Despite all that he went through to protect
Laurent and deliver the boy safely to The
Nest, Daryl still has his heart set on a return
to America, and he departs in the night against
Isabelle's protests.
After a brief stop in Normandy, Daryl boards
a boat on Omaha Beach.
He is about to set sail when he hears someone
calling his name, and discovers that Laurent
had followed him in order to say a proper
goodbye.
Unfortunately, his calls also have attracted
a fresh horde of walkers, and thus the first
season of "Daryl Dixon" ends with a cliffhanger
as Daryl has to choose whether to set sail
or turn back to save Laurent.
Despite being a brutal murderer and a sworn
enemy to Daryl Dixon, Stéphane is visibly
conflicted when Genet gives him the orders
to kill Laurent, and his resolve crumbles
when faced with actually murdering the child.
After returning to the Pouvoir hideout of
Maison Mère, Stephan attempts to lie his
way out of Genet's interrogation when he returns
without Daryl or Laurent.
Unfortunately for him, she doesn't believe
any of it, and orders her agents to torture
him for more information.
While Daryl Dixon and his comrades may have
escaped the wrath of Genet for now, their
fate now hinges on Stéphane's ability to
withstand torture — since he is one of the
few people who knows the secret location of
"The Nest."
Considering the gross levels of human experimentation
that Genet and the rest of the Pouvoir have
demonstrated, it's unlikely that Stéphane
will be able to hold out forever.
This perfectly sets up the impending conflict
between The Nest and the surviving members
of the Pouvoir, something that will likely
be a major focus in "Daryl Dixon" Season 2.
Most exciting to some longtime fans, the episode's
final moments reunite fans with "The Walking
Dead" staple Carol.
Just before the credits roll, the episode
cuts away to Freeport, Maine, where an unnamed
drifter is seen riding Daryl's iconic motorcycle.
The cyclist is pursued by Carol, and after
a brief scuffle, she knocks him unconscious
with a wrench.
She interrogates him and discovers that he
bought the motorcycle from survivors living
further up the road, and she locks him in
the trunk before riding off on Daryl's motorcycle.
Any "Walking Dead" fan will know that Carol
and Daryl are closer than perhaps any other
characters in the entire series, and have
been there for each other through more than
a decade of strife and heartbreak.
Despite never pursuing a romantic relationship,
they professed their love for each other before
Daryl left in the original series' finale.
Now, love has driven Carol to seek out her
friend after his disappearance — picking
up the trail in Maine, and setting up her
return for the next season of "The Walking
Dead: Daryl Dixon."
After leaving their relationship up in the
air in the original series finale, this reunion
could herald a true happy ending for both
Daryl and Carol.
Either way, we'll definitely be seeing more
of her—the second season has been announced
as "The Walking Dead: Daryl Dixon — The
Book of Carol."
While much of "Daryl Dixon" Season 1 centers
around Daryl's survival and desire to fight
his way home to his family, the finale helps
to clarify that the series is also a very
dysfunctional father-son story — one that
is bogged down by a long history of family trauma.
"Sounds hard."
"It was.
When he was around.
Which was hardly ever."
Throughout both the original "The Walking
Dead" series and "Daryl Dixon" we learn that
Daryl's father was extremely abusive and neglectful,
and that he was hardly ever there for him
or his brother Merle.
In a rare moment of vulnerability, Daryl tells
Isabelle that his grandfather had neglected
Daryl's father as well, and hints at the generational
trauma that has been passed down through the
Dixon family.
Now, this trauma threatens the development
of another young boy — Laurent, to whom
Daryl has become a pseudo-father figure.
The series tells us as much during the final
confrontation between Quinn and Laurent, where
Daryl encourages Laurent to kill his father's
reanimated body, and Laurent disowns his true
father once and for all.
When Daryl leaves in the middle of the night,
Isabelle boldly calls him out for repeating
the cycle of father-son abandonment that left
him so dysfunctional in the first place.
Thus, when Laurent arrives on the beach he
forces Daryl to finally confront the trauma
left behind by his father.
Will Daryl end up breaking the cycle and remaining
by Laurent's side as a real father figure?
Or will he succumb to the same weakness that
caused his own substantial abandonment issues?
Although this season finale places a heavy
emphasis on Daryl Dixon's attachment issues
and his newfound connection to Laurent, some
fans online aren't too thrilled about this
"family trauma" storyline that the show has
thrust into Daryl's lap.
As pointed out by many fans on Reddit, Daryl
has already served as a surrogate father figure
for R.J. and Judith Grimes, essentially raising
both of them after Rick Grimes' disappearance
in Season 9.
This somewhat invalidates Isabelle's argument
about "repeating the cycle," since staying
in France would be an act of abandonment in
itself.
"You think you are escaping history by doing
this but you are not.
You're repeating it."
As such, one could argue that Daryl's "abandonment
issues" concern his true family rather than
his newfound French allies.
To truly conquer his history of family dysfunction,
Daryl will need to return to America and resume
his role as the father figure to the Grimes
children.
If this explanation holds any weight, it could
set up a very interesting conflict for Season
2 of "Daryl Dixon" — wherein Laurent and
his religious allies attempt to stop Daryl
from returning to where he arguably truly
belongs.
While the ending of "Daryl Dixon" primarily
serves as a setup for the series' forthcoming
second season, it's important to clarify how
this season finale could tie into the rest
of the franchise as a whole.
Because Daryl is still in France at the end
of the series, this finale also makes it extremely
unlikely that we'll see Daryl in the upcoming
"Rick and Michonne" spinoff – something
which will no doubt disappoint plenty of fans,
since his original goal was to track down Rick Grimes.
On top of that, it's important to note that
both Negan and Maggie Rhee find themselves
in Manhattan in"The Walking Dead: Dead City."
If Daryl does return to America, it's not
out of the question that we'll see him and
Carol overshoot their destination and wind
up further down the East Coast — potentially
making a cameo in "Dead City" Season 2.
While some fans online were entirely unenthusiastic
about the way this finale put pressure on
Daryl Dixon to stay with Laurent, showrunner
David Zabel says that he had planned this
ending from the start.
Zabel explained during an interview with TheWrap,
"That was really my first pitch on the story.
At that point — he's not going to say it
because he's not that kind of guy — he is
like, 'I know I've got to do this.
This is an obligation.
Regardless of what I want for myself, I've
got to do this thing.'"
Zabel went on to say that this inner conflict
is hinted at earlier in the episode when Daryl
is trying to leave in the middle of the night.
Zabel explained that Norman Reedus chose to
play that scene with demonstrative frustration,
angrily throwing supplies into his bag because
he is torn on whether or not he should really leave.
Though this cliffhanger ending might not sit
well with some fans, it's clear that both
Zabel and Reedus wanted to emphasize Daryl
Dixon's inner turmoil when he finally arrives
on that beach — having discovered a new
kind of family, and nearly abandoning them
when they need him most.
It's safe to say that many fans were probably
disappointed when it was announced that the
rumored "Daryl and Carol" spinoff series would
be moving forward with only one of those characters.
On top of the fact that they are both fan-favorite
characters who have been around since Season
1, their chemistry together is one of the
undisputed highlights of the entire series.
Daryl's solemn journey overseas through France
feels a little bit lonely when you remember
he was supposed to be accompanied by his best
friend, though "The Walking Dead" primary
director Greg Nicotero says there was an unseen
benefit in removing her from Season 1.
He explained during an interview with TV Insider,
"I think having the show concentrate on Daryl
specifically and his experiences, to lay the
groundwork for that and then to bring Carol
in later, it allows for richer storytelling.
It just doesn't rely on two characters that
you already know because then there are less
places to go.
I think it allowed Daryl to grow."
Nicotero went on to clarify that the return
of actress Melissa McBride in the finale is
also a boon for the series, since both McBride
and Norman Reedus will have a good deal of
involvement with the development of Carol
and Daryl's next chapter.
As for what that next chapter will hold, fans
will just have to wait until "The Book of
Carol" drops in 2024.